[Music]
okay welcome everybody to another
endgame video uh it's been quite a while
since I've made an endgame video but
today I felt inspired and I felt
inspired by the fact that a couple of
days ago uh at the time of recording the
Champions chess tour concluded in uh
Toronto this was the final of a
season-long event held by chess.com
and to the surprise of exactly no one
Magnus Carlson dominated a lot of you
watching uh were probably watching the
event live maybe some of you were even
in Toronto uh it was an incredible event
that featured Magnus Hikaru Wesley so oi
Resa fua and others It produced some
absolutely incredible action uh some
crazy Armageddon games uh and of course
where would we be without one time
scramble after another the time control
was 15 minutes with a 10 second
increment so we had time scrambles and
blunders Galore in the CCT but my job on
this channel is to pull out to call the
most instructive content uh from all of
these tournaments and to present it to
you in sort of bite-sized portions and
so I decided to go through the games uh
from the CCT and select what I believe
to be are the most interesting uh the
most instructive the most noteworthy
endings uh from the three stages of the
Champions chess tour final we had uh the
round robin stage then we had the
survival stage and of course we had the
final between Magnus Carlson and the
runnerup Wesley So and I've selected six
very interesting end games some of them
feature Magnus Carlson others feature
notbe abdusattorov and hikaro Nakamura
uh we will go through them one by one
and as usual with endgame videos I will
give you ample opportunities to pause
the video uh and try to solve exercises
on your own uh and most importantly I
hope that this video will be instructive
uh entertaining and you will be able to
take home uh specific lessons and
takeaways on various different types of
endings so for starters um let's jump in
with the position in front of us we will
go in sort of reverse chronological
order uh we start with a very simple
position this is kind of the appetizer
round uh you can consider this just sort
of a warm-up um to get your brain
worrying and working in the right
direction literally and figuratively as
see because you might have been staring
at this position all along as I've been
blabbering and trying to figure out
where the pawns are going and don't
worry I'll help you out with that so
this first example comes from the final
between Magnus Carlson and uh Wesley so
Magnus has the white pieces and Wesley
has black we are facing uh the WID side
Magnus Carlson Wesley's pawns are in
fact going forward this is very very bad
news for Magnus who is currently up a
rook no that is not a wrong position
setup yes he is up a rook uh but yes he
is also completely losing because he
simply cannot stop these connected
passers which are both on the second
rank but before resigning the game
Magnus Carlson sets up an absolutely
devilish trick first things first let's
see if you can figure out the devilish
idea that Magnus Carlson implemented in
this position to give Wesley so one last
test so you might be attracted by two
different factors uh that may lead you
to believe that white has uh some
defensive potential the first is the C
Pawn but it doesn't take long to
understand that the C Pawn is way too
far away to cause black any problems if
you play C5 black is just going to make
a queen and that will be that the second
more pertinent factor is the arrangement
of the rook and the Knight on the
seventh Rank and you might be familiar
with a whole host of various mechanisms
uh in which the Knight and the Rook
essentially pursue the king uh I either
until Checkmate or lock the king up in
some sort of Perpetual check and and so
your instinct might be to start checking
to play Knight H7 check and to try to
box the king in with a series of Knight
checks and indeed if the King goes to
the right then everything is groovy if
it goes to h8 uh then you can deliver an
Arabian mate on H7 unfortunately the
king is going to run the other way black
is going to play King f8 and if white
continues to check the king is simply
going to escape uh to the left side of
the board Knight F6 King to d8 and after
Rook D7 King C8 white is out of
meaningful checks and on the next move
black is going to make uh one Queen and
then a second Queen but Magnus does not
give up there he plays The Very thematic
move Rook B7 to D7 and this is a
worthwhile mechanism uh for you to
remember the point is that the Rook now
cuts off the king along the defile and
if black simply makes a queen now the
mechanism leads to Perpetual check after
Knight H7 check King E8 the Knight
Returns to F6 and the king is unable to
keep running to the left of course the
Knight also protects the rook and if
you're not familiar with this mechanism
then either write it down or take a
snapshot of it with your phone because
this arrangement of the rook and the
Knight is extremely important it's
allowed so many players through the
years to save a lot of hopeless
positions but now comes part two of the
exercise does Wesley so acqu to the draw
or does he have a h resource to cut
through this mechanism and win the game
Let's flip the board now it's your turn
to face the black side remember black is
going up now can Wesley so cut through
and thwart this drawing mechanism the
answer of course is yes otherwise I
would not be posing uh this exercise to
you now logically the only piece that
could do anything about this mechanism
is the Knight on D3 but the move Knight
E5 doesn't actually help so Wesley so
begins with a check on
F4 uh Magnus moves the king to F3 and
now comes the critical move Knight F4
drops back to H5 this is the only
winning move it's a brilliant defensive
idea and the idea of this move is very
very simple the pawns are
self-sufficient they will promote when
the time is right the point is that
after Knight H7 King E8 white no longer
has access to the F6 square with his
Knight and after Knight H5 Magnus was
simply forced to resign the game if
white takes on H5 black doesn't even
have to rush with promotion we can
simply recapture on H5 and once again
the pawns are going to Prevail um I did
do a knight versus pawns uh endgame
video in which I talked about uh the
idea of using a check against the king
to get the Knight to the appropriate
spot we will see this again and again in
end games involving Knights uh and it's
very important to understand that a
single minor piece the placement of the
King on a particular Square can change
the evaluation of the position if the
King was not on G2 but on H2 or on G3
the evaluation would be drawn it's
because the King was on G2 and because
it was checkable by the Knight that
Wesley so was able to win this game
although he did end up losing the finals
match so that was a warm-up exercise now
we get to the more fun exercises let's
flip the board again and let's go to our
second example uh once again it features
Magnus Carlson who has the white pieces
against of fuia now this particular game
which was in Armageddon has kind of made
the rounds you might have actually been
watching this live uh this position
might be familiar to you uh but it
contains a lot of instructive details
that have kind of remained behind the
scenes so this is the position that we
start from Magnus has the white pieces
his pawns are going forward and clearly
he is trying to win the game first
things first pause the video and try to
come up with the cleanest way of winning
this game for white and I apologize for
the Perpetual for the compulsive water
drinking I've just had a long stream
today and I've done a lot of talking so
I'm on the cusp of losing my voice
hopefully it lasts me through through
this
video okay so how do we approach uh this
position um the basic idea is that we
have a pass Pawn on E6 and black has a
pass Pawn on F3 so white has two
fundamental approaches white can push E7
and try to win the pawn race or White
can try to stop the F Pawn with the
Knight now if you're playing and you
have this position in a classical game
it makes sense to start by calculating
the move E7 because it is the most
forcing move and E7 leads to a really
beautiful line believe it or not the
move E7 gives up the win and after E7
black is able to salvage a miracle drop
and black does not play the move F2 if
black plays F2 then white can simply
capture the Knight and with a a knight
and an extra Pawn white wins pretty
easily instead black Begins by
delivering a check on F7 now you might
have seen that and said okay but after
Knight F7 check white can shift the king
over to E6 dominating the Knight black
has nothing better than to push the pawn
white promotes to a queen black promotes
to a queen now very importantly the
queen protects the Knight but you might
have said yes I saw all of this and I
calculated one step further the Queen
can deliver a check on G8 Force the king
to the side we take the Knight on F7 and
we are completely winning except we are
not completely winning because it is
black to move and you should know that
in Queen end games it's not always about
who has the most extra material theci
side whose move it is holds tremendous
power because in Queen end games the
king is generally a super vulnerable
piece and black has an incredibly nasty
check on C4 here and if you manage to
calculate this far then big kudos to You
Queen C4 check is the drawing resource
the King has to maintain contact with
the queen but if it moves up to E7 then
white gives away the Knight with check
and the draw is Elementary so King F6 is
the only feasible move and now another
accurate check is delivered on D4
amazingly the King which is blocked by
its own Queen and its Mobility
circumscribed also by Black's King is
unable uh to move away from the checks
without stumbling into Queen takes E5
checking F5 Queen takes E5 once again as
a check and King E6 Queen C4 check is a
repetition of moves a pretty amazing
drawing idea and this is why after E7 F2
it would be a grave mistake for white to
promote to a queen which is absolutely
crazy E8 Queen check looks like the game
is over but black interposes with check
and as a matter of fact this is winning
I think after King E7 uh but the win
here would be very very difficult to
achieve and if white plays King E6 and
we have transposed in into the drawing
line um that we just analyzed via the uh
E7 Knight F7 check move so E7 actually
gives up the win and the correct
approach is to stop the pawn with the
Knight but there are two ways to do that
we can play Knight D3 and we can play
Knight E4 both of those moves win the
game but one wins the game a lot more
cleanly than the other the correct move
and the move that wins most cleanly is
Knight to E4 okay Knight to E4 stopping
the pawn and preparing to push E7 Knight
E4 finishes the game almost immediately
there is just nothing the black can do
here the only attempt is Knight B7 check
but now we use the kind of zigzag method
we play King to C6 um it would be also
possible to play King C7 but this is a
little bit sloppier here black has
Knight C5 and you still have some work
to do you can play Knight take C5 and
promote with check but that drags the
game on instead it's uh more precise to
go King to C6 Force the Knight back to
d8 and now zigzag forward to D7 this
simply ends the game black can give up
the Knight for the pawn uh but then
there's no further progress to be made
and white simply pushes the B Pawn up
the board and if black plays Knight B7
then E7 ends the game E8 Queen check is
coming so if you found Knight E4 kudos
to you but in the game with just a
couple of seconds left on his clock both
players had been surviving on increment
for something like 15 moves at this
Point Magnus played the less precise
winning move Knight to D3 now what is
the difference between Knight E4 and
Knight D3 simply use the process of
comparison by which I mean consider the
squares that the Knight is covering on
D3 and the squares that the Knight is
covering on e4 and you should see that
on e4 the Knight covers this very
important Square on F6 which does not
allow Black's King to meaningfully
approach the pawn of course black and
play King F5 but this does not help
because white has E7 anyway way in the
game after Knight D3 fuja was able to
find King F6 well white has to push E7
and it suddenly turns out that after
Knight F7 check white is very very close
to Simply losing this Pawn the King has
to has to maintain contact with the pawn
and so Magnus moves his King up to D7
and in this position fua lost on time as
he was making the move F2 which is
actually a brilliant defensive move the
move F2 forces white to find an only
winning move and a brilliant winning
idea in order to re in the full point so
the final exercise in this example pause
the video here and see if you can figure
out what the only winning sequence is in
this position and those of you who spend
time on like chess social media you
might have seen this on Twitter or in a
in an article uh this has already kind
of made the rounds white to play okay so
the first important thing is to
determine why we can't simply take the
pawn on F2 well the reason is that F2
was actually a deflection tactic it was
a simple deflection right the point is
to deflect the knight from D3 and to
deflect the knight from its control over
the E5 square and once again black is
waging a war to try to force the king to
lose contact with the E7 Pawn this is a
very common defensive technique in
Knight end games you basically circle
around and keep delivering checks until
the king gives up and loses contact with
the pawn so if King D7 you just keep
checking Knight F7 King D7 Knight E5 Etc
the only meaningful winning attempt here
is not King d8 that walks into a fork
but King to E8 getting behind the pawn
but this move gives black a very
valuable Tempo and even though black
does not have any checks we are able to
surround the pawn with our Knight Knight
to G6 is the winning move is the drawing
move that is and amazingly even though
white now has the knight at his Disposal
White is now unable to save the E7 Pawn
you can give a check on e4 but it's a
meaningless check black plays King E6
and Black's King is going to circle
around D6 E6 and F6 as necessary
depending on where the Knight delivers
the check you can go Knight C5 you can
go Knight B7 it literally does not
matter where you give checks as long as
the black king essentially circles
between E6 and D6 white is completely
unable to make progress Knight F7 King
E6 white has danced around the entire
board but black simply goes between D6
and E6 notice that King F6 is actually a
grave error because here there's a
beautiful little geometrical sequence
Knight H7 Chuck and suddenly the Knight
gets to f8 forcing the Knight trade this
is how tricky Knight end games are I am
preparing uh the first night endgame
video and the amount of examples I see
where even Ultra experienced players
make mistakes like this in what seem to
be very Elementary positions is pretty
crazy it's so easy to forget about these
various tricks the Knight is a devilish
piece so you actually have to stick
between E6 and D6 specifically and
actually you might begin to wonder why
Knight G6 and not Knight C6 here the
reason is also very elegant why he plays
Knight E4 check white initiates the
dance okay King F6 blah blah blah if
King to D6 then there is the same idea
on the opposite side isn't this
beautiful we just saw this with the
Knight on f8 and the Black Knight on G6
now we see this with the Knight on d8
and the Black Knight on C6 if black goes
the other way if black goes to F6 here
um here the winning idea I actually
didn't fully Analyze This Is Here King
E6 Knight f8 check King F6 and now there
is an incredible move Knight to
G6 insane sacrifice pulling the king
away from the pawn and now King f8 wins
the game black is forced to give up the
Knight for the pawn and white now is
able to promote uh the G Pawn so
amazingly Knight C6 does not work only
Knight G6 draws the game and you might
now ask well wait doesn't white have the
same type of trick with the Knight on G6
and the answer is no if white tries the
same type of trick right if white plays
Knight C5 check King D6 Knight B7 check
Knight d8 check and Knight to C6 which
is the same exact thing on the opposite
side of the board here the problem is
Black's King is in very close proximity
uh to the B Pawn so after King F7 black
can give up the Knight for the pawn and
play King B5 such is the depth of night
end games with only a couple of Pawns
left on the board so let's review that
one more time because I know that was a
lot first of all and we haven't even
gotten to the winning move yet what we
have determined is that the only drawing
move in this position is Knight to G6
okay and the mechanism of Defense should
be very clear to once again the reason
why Knight to C6 doesn't work is because
after Knight E4 check
and Knight C5 check and Knight D7 check
and Knight f8 check white plays the
Incredible move Knight to G6 and after
King takes G6 if black doesn't take the
Knight then white can still step away
from the pawn because the Knight now
defends the pawn um and here white plays
king f8 and the key difference is that
with the Knight on G6 the black king was
on C6 with the Knight on C6 the black
king was on G6 the symmetry of this end
game is something out of like a da Vinci
painting like the inter relationship
between the C6 and G6 squares is pretty
incredible long story short um the move
e the move Knight takes F2 squanders the
win the move E8 Queen also squanders the
win here black simply promotes and one
extra Pawn is not enough clearly not
enough to win the end game and so big
kudos to you if you were able to
determine that E8 equals Knight check
and under promotion if there ever was
one is the only winning move white makes
a knight with check then white calmly
recaptures the pawn on F2 and it's not
necessarily clear at the outset that
this is a winning end game because if
black is able to give up the Knight for
the pawn it is a theoretical draw two
knights are not able to mate uh the bear
King but if you Analyze This endgame it
turns out the black is simply unable to
approach this Pawn with his Knight for
example if Knight E5 check white plays
King C7 and Black's problem is going to
be that anytime he gets close to the
pawn white simply forces the trade of
knights I looked at this end game it is
winning for white with a little bit of
careful play but I will not bog you down
with uh the detail so this is a very
rare example of a situation in which
only an under promotion wins the game
the under promotion is the only move uh
which wins cleanly every other move
squanders the Victory and that is how
the game could have ended if alza did
not flag of course maybe Magnus would
have captured on F2 and then well we
have no idea what would have happened
sadly ala flagged as he was playing the
move F2 and this will forever remain
behind the scenes that was our second
example now what's interesting is that
as I was analyzing this I started to
remember something I started to remember
a Blitz game that I had played a couple
of years ago against none other than
alza fuia himself I was like man
something about this Carlson fuia game
really rings the bell and so I dug deep
into my game archive and I found the
game against ala f
um which I remembered through the lens
of that Carlson peria game and we join
the battle in this position I have the
black pieces uh this was played
approximately two years ago in a casual
3 plus zero game you can also find uh
the a clip of this game and me streaming
it on YouTube if you search Daniel niski
under promotion so this was the position
in which the fun begins I have
sacrificed a knight and I've sacrificed
it in order to generate a major Pawn
majority on the queen side the goal for
black is very clear we want to promote a
pawn if we don't promote a pawn then we
probably lose the game because we're
down a minor piece and so the big
question here first question do we play
B3 or do we play B takes C3 pause the
video try to make that determination
pretty simple question okay so this is a
matter of straightforward calculation
it's important to to determined point
out that in in Pawn end games you
generally want to make the pa the pass
Pawn that is furthest away from the
enemy King so if the Knight was gone
then your your instinct should be to
play B3 but with knights on the board
the patterns are a little bit different
you basically want to create the pass
Pawn that is hardest for the Knight to
stop uh and so by that logic the correct
move is actually BC B3 is a terrible
blunder because after the trade White's
Knight is simply able to stop the B Pawn
from D2 and then White's King stops the
black king from progressing with King F2
and white actually wins the game because
the Knight will park itself on B1 and
fully blockade Black's connected passers
so B3 loses the game I played B take C3
thinking okay the game is basically over
but oza does not go gentle into that
good night Knight F3 setting a trap if
you blindly play C2 the Knight picks off
the pawn with a fork so I realized well
I should probably get my king out of the
way and while I'm at it I should
probably eliminate uh the pawn on F4 so
King takes F4 was on the board and now
Ala plays a devilish move King to F2
which was not on my radar at all I had
assumed that Knight E1 was forced and
here the win is pretty Elementary our
King makes it to the D2 Square in time
then we push C2 the Knight is forced uh
to sacrifice itself for the first C pawn
and then the second C Pawn uh decides
the outcome of the game Knight F3 check
you just go King D1 and push the C Pawn
this is very easy but alzo plays King F2
and suddenly I realize what his idea is
if we push C2 then white plays Knight D4
and after we promote to a queen white
picks off the newly promoted Queen with
knight2 and wins the game King E4 simply
Knight takes C1 and to my horror I
realized that if I don't push the pawn
then white can fully stop their progress
by dropping the Knight back to E1 and so
frantically I started trying to find
something and it was pretty quickly that
I understood the path to Victory now
having seen the Carlson f a game the
correct path should be you should be
pretty primed uh to see to see the right
approach here but nonetheless pause the
video see if you can figure out uh the
path to Victory here for black same
exact theme okay so of course we play C2
and after Knight D1 we don't make a
queen we make a knight I mean chess is a
pretty incredible game it's just insane
to me on a basic level that there are
situations where you have to make like
the much less valueable piece such is
the beauty of like the uniqueness of the
knight's Movement we make a knight and
black now has a completely winning end
game because we simply have a past cwn
and this past cwn is way too far
Advanced our King is way too active uh
and the rest of the game is fairly
straightforward I will kind of fast
forward to one other interesting moment
um I pushed my Pawn I brought my knight
back I did everything correct and then
alza was desperately trying to stop my
Pawn we got a pretty similar situation
to the Magnus for game and in this
position I found one last finesse to
seal the game in style black to play and
win the game on the spot so the correct
move here is the deflection sacrifice
Knight to F3 check giving away the
knight in order to make possible King B2
followed by C1 Queen we made a couple
more meaningless moves and I won the
game if you play the immediate King to
B2 you actually allow white to sacrifice
the Knight for the pawn and winning this
position is actually pretty hard because
White's King is going to make a a beine
for the G7 Pawn there's going to be a
pawn race black is winning with some
precise play but why bother with this
when you have the simple n F3 check
sacking the Knight and then King B2 and
C1 Queen so the Magnus game reminded me
of an under promotion that I had against
the very same
alza fuja under promotion in the endgame
is one of my favorite favorite themes
okay on we go to our next
example okay now this one is absolutely
a the freaking wall we're about 26
minutes into the video um I'm hoping to
keep this at about 45 to 50 minutes so
we'll see if I manag to do that we might
have to split this into two parts um
because the examples are actually
getting more complex now much like the
Carlson fuia game this game will
probably end up as one of the most
famous um rapid games of all time uh
this was the first match game between
Carlson and Fabiano Carana uh the time
scramble that led up to this position
was already pretty crazy there were a
lot of twists and turns a lot of
turnarounds finally fabon Carana
developed a massive attack against
Magnus Carlson's King uh and that led up
to this position on Black's 78th move
and both sides once again are down to
just essentially increment couple of
seconds per move so in this position
it's black to play and uh we will face
the white side in this example even
though I'll ask you some questions from
Black's perspective now Fabi Carana
plays by far the most obvious move in
this position and it turns out that that
obvious move is what leads to Calamity
it doesn't spoil the win but it makes
the win a lot harder to achieve first
step is to pause the video and see if
you can find the most precise path to
Victory the cleanest path to Victory so
some of you may already know that
Fabiano Carana instantly played Rook C6
Jack thinking that the game is over
because he skewers and wins uh a full
Queen and then has a full three pass
pawns that he can use in the subsequent
Pawn race to deflect White's Rook but
instead the cleanest win the engine
gives a checkmate with Queen A7 but the
most human path to Victory is actually
Queen to C6 check then you play Rook F4
check and that's not the end of the
story Black's King White's King drops
back to E3 and yes white does make a new
Queen but just look at the fact that
black has three extra pawns and Black's
King is completely safe the simplest
here is Queen E4 check followed by Queen
takes B4 check and having reached this
position Magnus would have almost
certainly resigned black can win this
position in a variety of ways he can
trade Queens uh you can Checkmate the
white king but this is completely
winning even with just a couple of
seconds on your clock but can we blame
Fabiano uh for immediately playing the
most natural move Rook C6 check well
Magnus drops back to D4 Fabiano takes on
C4 Magnus Carlson takes back and you
would think that the game is over but if
you look a little bit more carefully you
should very quickly realize that the
game in a certain sense is only
beginning this is the power of putting
your Rook behind a pass Pawn Pawn on D7
and The Rook on D3 demand the black
Queen's immediate attention well black
has no choice but to put the queen
behind the pawn and now if you've seen
end games like this before and this is a
pretty typical type of endgame
construction where the rook and the pawn
are kind of holding back the Queen the
general the kind of stock winning
strategy in such positions is to use
whatever pawns you have to throw them
down the board and to try to deflect The
Rook from whichever Pawn it's defending
in order to free up to jailbreak uh the
queen and of course that sounds very
easy and very neat but in practice it is
filled with all sorts of difficulties
and indeed Magnus Carlson first of all
has another pass pawn and he sends that
pass Pawn up the board and things are
getting really really scary for black
because with just a couple of Tempe
white is going to send this his own Pawn
to B8 deflect the black queen and then
promote the other Pawn with an extra
Rook what does black do well black
actually is winning here but the path to
Victory is narrow and it's incredibly
instructive there's a lot of beautiful
details in this end game so let's go
through it slowly First Step pause the
video see if you can figure out if you
can work out the entire winning sequence
for black I'll give you a small hint
it's actually not as hard as it may
appear the key is not to be afraid of
White's Pawns
all right go ahead and take your
time all right so the correct first move
is H4 paradoxically the correct strategy
is simply to push Black's pawns as if
nothing is the matter and the key detail
that you have to see is that after B7
the pawns are both located on the
seventh rank suddenly the queen is able
to put itself right in the little gap
between the pawns and this is an amazing
construction whichever file the King
goes to the queen captures the pawn that
is on that file with a check obviously
King D D4 loses immediately and if the
King goes to the B file then black
captures the pawn with check and then
uses checks to get the queen back to its
blockading post on d8 the alligator you
know snaps his Jaws then rushes back
into the water for example King C2 Queen
C7 and queen d8 and now you can win in a
variety of ways you can just get your
king to E7 and Sack the queen for the
pawn you can continue pushing this is
completely winning this is what Fabio
Carana failed to Pere with just a couple
of seconds he panicked thinking that B6
is coming and thinking that it will be
deadly and he delivered a completely
useless check on C7 that wasted Tempo
and actually should have cost him and
did cost him the win Magnus drops his
King back to B3 Bobby realizes that he's
got no checks and he has to move the
queen back to d8 now of course white is
unable to play B6 here because the queen
will capture the pawn with check and
amazingly Magnus Carlson now has a draw
but as is so often the case in these
types of end games only one move only
one move guarantees him the draw it is a
king move that should not come as a
surprise to you because you need to
prepare B6 but where on Earth is the
king supposed to go there's a lot of
options King C4 King A4 King A2 King C2
where on Earth should the king hide
itself in order to make the draw this is
an exceedingly difficult exercise but if
you're feeling brave and this is how you
learn and how you get better at end
games right you challenge yourself you
get things wrong and that's how you
understand these subtle details that you
can actually apply in your own games
where should the king go so the correct
answer is back to C2 the correct answer
is King to C2 now what happens here is
that after black implements the same
idea H4 B6 G5 B7 now the check on C7 is
no longer effective because the king is
able to hide on D1 this is the point and
now black is unable to stop both both
pawns at the same time it's still a draw
but it is now black who has to walk on
eggshells and so move King C2 draws the
game after H4 B6 G5 B7 black can try G4
and in this position there is yet
another land mine to avoid most players
would very happily promote the queen and
think only white has a chance to win the
game but no the past pawns actually
Prevail black plays G3 and the white
king is one tempo short right if the
King was on D2 white would play King E2
and stop the pawns here The Rook is
operating all alone you can try Rook D4
but now the third Pawn rushes into to
the rescue G5 and amazingly this is a
win for black if you play Rook G4 the
black king comes in this is actually a
pretty incredible construction that I
don't think I've ever seen before um and
black wins the game The Rook is pushed
away and black promotes both both of his
pawns there's there's just nothing that
white can do if you try to stop the pawn
like this this then black just plays H3
and G2 is coming and if you try to use
your King well clearly you're just not
fast enough white loses immediately so
incredibly B8 Queen is a mistake white
has to find the Ultra accurate Rook to
C3 intending Rook C8 it's very important
to keep essentially the new queen and
the Rook on the board here after G3 Rook
C8 black has no choice but to take on D7
white promotes to a queen and this once
again is a draw black can deliver
Perpetual to the white king white King
has no hiding spot uh and so this is a
draw by Perpetual check and so King C2
was the only drawing move now that's
interesting but you might wonder well
why is Magnus Carlson's move losing
Magnus played the move King to A4 might
wonder well doesn't this lead
essentially to the exact same types of
lines well here's the difference Fabiano
correctly plays H4 Magnus plays B6 and
it is in this position that Fabiano
panics with one second on on his clock
he accidentally pushes the pawn to H3
forgetting that The Rook captures the
pawn with check Fabiano just like grabs
his head Magnus takes the pawn with
check and now only white is playing for
the win instead big question what would
happen after G5 after B7 G4 now it
should Dawn on you why the king is so
misplaced on A4 if white plays B8 well
we already know the outcome of this end
game this is even a worse version for
white because the king is in timbuk 2
and the pawns Prevail we already know
that but if white tries to play Rook C3
this is the significance of keeping the
king far away from the Queen's line of
fire here black picks up the D7 Pawn
with a check forking the other Pawn so
the King on A4 is very very misplaced
and this was the winning approach for
Fabi on aaran how did he miss this with
one second left right in the game Fabby
panics with H3 Magnus says thank you
very much for the pawn he comes back to
D3 and now it is Fabiano who is fighting
for the draw he plays King F7 Magnus
pushes B7 King E7 by Fabby he is just in
time King B5 by Magnus Carlson he brings
his King into the into the fire Into The
Fray King to C6 G4 Rook E3 check and
this was the final critical moment an
exhausted Fabiano Carana a frustrated
Fabiano Carana blunders horribly with
King F6 allowing Rook E8 and he resigns
in shame the queen has no checks and
white promotes both of his Queens what
sick irony it's not Black's pawns that
end up promoting it's actually both of
White's pawns instead King F7 actually
kept a draw because now if white plays
Rook E8 there is Perpetual check
obviously with Queen F6 check and queen
C3 check and white is unable to evade uh
the diagonal checks Queen G3 Queen C3
Queen A3 uh Etc so the finale of the
game was a little bit
anticlimactic but the details and the
subtleties of this queen versus ren game
are pretty incredible
and this reminds me of something that my
coach would would always tell me about
converting endgame advantages he would
always say that when you miss the most
obvious win when you miss a very
Elementary win the subsequent wins
become harder and harder and harder and
you're a lot less likely to find them so
after Fabby missed Queen C6 the
subsequent win was like many orders of
magnitude harder than Queen C6 and this
is what always happens right the winds
become harder and more narrow and
suddenly you find yourself fighting for
a draw but pretty incredible that the
only drawing move here is King to C2
hiding behind The Rook moving away from
the queen Magnus Carlson is a magician
he ends up winning this game and
obviously winning the
tournament okay on we go um I have two
more examples that I wanted to get
through we're at 38 minutes I think
we're going to make it but I don't want
to rush through anything okay now this
is absolutely epic this example uh is
one of my favorites it's honestly a
wildly instru dtive opposite colored
Bishop endgame now when you hear the
term opposite colored Bishop endgame
most people with you know even a nodding
acquaintance with chess endgames
immediately think draw opposite colored
Bishop end games are known for their
Ultra drawsh Tendencies and that's
pretty easy to understand because when
you operate on an uncontested diagonal
you're able to blockade a a chain of
Pawns you're able to set up a light squ
blockade or a dark squ blockade and you
get into many situations where even the
one side is up several pawns and we will
see just such a situation in this game
because the other side has a monopoly on
a particular color Square the pawns are
unable to move forward and essentially
uh the attacking side is unable to make
progress now in this position um Notre
Becka dorov has managed to create
serious winning chances despite the
opposite colored Bishops he has the
white pieces here and he has a clear
Advantage because both his bishop and
his King are much more actively placed
uh than their counterparts and currently
the G7 Pawn is hanging and you should
quickly understand that if black plays
F6 check the white king jumps into G6
eliminates the G7 pawn and on goes the H
Pawn all the way to promotion Hikaru
whose clock was dwindling started to
panic at this moment he wasn't expecting
uh this end game to present him any
difficulties and he makes a very
interesting move but that very
interesting move turns out to be a
losing blunder the way to draw this end
game is actually through a series of
very beautiful ideas that are almost
impossible to find uh within the context
of a Time scramble and so I won't
necessarily pose this to you as an
exercise I'm just going to show you what
the drawing strategy was the drawing
strategy one of several was to start
with G6 white of course pushes H4 and
now an extremely difficult move Bishop
to E8 putting the bishop right on what
seems to be the worst Square on the
board now why is two approaches here if
white pushes H5 there is a tactical idea
in this position at this point the
basics of this idea should Dawn on you
why did we put the bishop on E8 so that
we could play This brilliant move F6
check using tactics to stop the pawn
bishop F6 Bishop takes H5 and black
draws comfortably as a matter of fact
white can even lose this end game it's
always possible right if white tries to
shoulder the black king then suddenly
black pushes E3 and because black is
closer to the C Pawn we encountered
these types of examples in our Pawn in
game videos black actually collects both
pawns and wins the game now the second
approach for white is to say no no no no
I'm not going to let you push your F
Pawn I'm going to stick my own Bishop on
F6 and now black manages to go around
the other side Bishop to A4 white pushes
H5 black trades on H5 and now sacking
the pawn E3 F takes E3 and the bishop
stops the pawn from C2 and here black
sets up an impervious blockade and this
is a great illustration of what I uh
said in the introduction to this example
white is an extra Pawn it's a pass Pawn
on H6 and because black has a complete
Monopoly on the light squares white is
completely unable to make progress black
is just going to shuffle between G6 and
H7 at infinum there is nothing that
white can do so by combining these two
ideas one on this diagonal and one on
this diagonal black is able to stop the
H Pawn miraculously but Hikaru tries a
much more radical approach he plays the
move F5 which at First Sight might seem
like just an insane move but if you look
at it a little bit more carefully this
move actually starts to make a lot of
sense he wants to to drop the king back
to F7 and his logic is that after white
takes on F5 and the King moves back to
F7 it's going to be very difficult for
white to create a past Pawn White's Pawn
structure on the king side is
essentially ruined and hikaro was
banking on the fact that his King
placement is going to give him an
impervious
blockade okay is that in fact the case
well actually no white is winning in
this position and in a Time scramble
appreciating all the subtleties of even
an ostensibly simple position like this
one is absolutely
impossible now end games vary in terms
of the type of difficulty that they
present some end games are difficult
from a calculational standpoint they're
hard to calculate there's a lot going on
end games are difficult conceptually for
example in this end game it's not like
you have to calculate a long variation
rather you have to figure out the
winning setup black is just going to
shuffle with his Bishop there's nothing
that black can do in this position other
than just Shuffle between random squares
the point is to find the correct
arrangement of our King our pawns and
our Bishop such that we prevent black
from setting up a blockade on the light
squares this is a great exercise in
conceptual thinking pause the video see
if you can find the correct setup okay
so the correct idea uh involves moving
the king from G5 which seems like the
most active Square over to the center of
the board the simplest win is King to
F4 now black of course has to defend uh
this Pawn with Bishop C6 now we get the
king to the center of the board stage
two of our plan is to cycle the bishop
over to G5 in order to create a a force
field which will prevent Black's King
from moving up to F6 it'll also uh make
sure that we can always meet G6 with F6
actually F takes G6 also wins the game
black continues to shuffle with Bishop
B7 now we Dodge back to D4 we attack the
C4 Pawn now this is not a pawn that
black can afford to give up because then
we get an outside passer on C3 black has
to defend um or black has to
Counterattack the F5 Pawn Now we move
back and take the E4 Pawn so stage one
and two has been complete we have gotten
the bishop to the right spot we have
gotten the king to the right spot now
it's time for stage three black
continues to shuffle whatever Bishop B7
check Bishop C8 here is stage three we
push H4 and finally it is time for us to
create a pass Pawn with F6 black has to
acquest to the trade and we get this
very interesting situation with past F
and H pawns and because of the excellent
placement of White's King black is
unable to set up a blockade here is why
black continues to shuffle right Bishop
C8 whatever actually Bishop C8 white can
play H5 so the most resilient move is
Bishop F3 now we can play King back to
F4 chasing away the bishop here we go
King
F5 um we we do a series of like small
zigzags here we're trying to basically
push F4 again black plays Bishop F3 here
we can play Bishop to G5 actually this
is a little bit over complicating the
lightly let me just make sure that I
have the right idea see this is so
complicated that uh even having analyzed
this position I'm still um I'm still
struggling to get the moves right I'm
pretty sure that we can also start with
the move F4 yes we can start with the
move F4 just to prevent this whole
Bishop F3 nonsense so we can start with
F4 black plays Bishop E7 now we can push
F6 okay there we go and this is just
winning black shuffles we push H4 we
push F5 we drop the bishop back around
we can play we can play King F4 we can
play Bishop d8 now the king comes back
around to G5 and the win is pretty
Elementary we just like push the pawns
H5
H6 now we can play where's the win yeah
F6 this is actually Ultra complicated
King G8 King F5 yes King E5 and now the
final stage okay this is actually a
great experience for me because what you
can see is I I spent a couple hours
preparing this video and I just kind of
assumed I was under the influence that
once you played F6 and reached this
ideal setup the win was really
Elementary but actually it's not and it
requires one more step so after we
complete the process of just like moving
the pawns to H6 and F6 there's one more
subtlety which is to get the king back
to the queen side back to D4 black
continues to shuffle and now the
critical idea let's say we go Bishop B7
black plays King F7 if black moves the
bishop then we can go H7 and F7 so
actually this square is very important
for the bishop black has to remain on
this diagonal and now we force zong with
King D5 there we go we we force zuk Vang
of course black can knock give up the C4
Pawn if black plays King G8 we go King
E6 Bishop G6 and now the final final
detail a beautiful sacrifice H7
deflecting either the king or the Bishop
from its protection of the F7 square and
finally finally we have beaten the
blockade This Is What It Takes ladies
and Gentlemen let's go through that
again one more
time so what is the winning plan very
simple right stage one we get the king
from G5 over to E5 K F4 E5 stage two we
get the bishop to G5 stage three is we
go King to D4 and we force black to th
Play Bishop A6 or Bishop C8 basically we
win the E4 Pawn by attacking the C4 Pawn
boom stage four we push F6 but we we do
it after pushing F4 so that Black's
Bishop doesn't land on F3 um if Black's
Bishop lands on F3 here then we can like
cycle around with our King until we were
able to play F4 Bishop C8 we push um
okay we push F4 we can also push H4 it
doesn't really matter we push F6
and this is stage four stage five is we
get these two pawns to H6 and F6
respectively and we do that by shuffling
our King where needed stage six we get
our King over to the queen side tying
the bishop down both to the C4 pawn and
to the H7 Square the bishop sticks on E7
and this is the completion of the
penultimate stage black is now in full
zong by the way if King E8 then again
there is this trick with
Checkmate and the final stage is using
tactics to break down the blockade one
final time I mean absolute Insanity
right and I'm sure I made some
inaccuracies there in my analysis uh
please forgive me I I did my best but
the point of these videos is also just
to to inspire you a little bit right to
to inspire you to analyze on your own um
and to show you just how complex these
end games are now we haven't even gotten
to the game continuation yet in the game
Notre backck plays what what seems to be
a completely innocuous move he plays the
move H4 okay well that seems completely
normal but it actually gives up the win
black now drops the bishop into A4 Notre
Beck starts the correct winning uh
procedure it seems with King F4 and King
E5 and you might say well what on Earth
has changed right everything seems to be
the same and yet what has changed is
that Black's Bishop is now occupying an
ideal defensive position it's occupying
D3 whereas in the winning line the black
Bishop is unable to get to D3 right it's
unable to get to D3 because we simply
eliminate the E4 Pawn whereas in the
game hikaro was able to get his Bishop
to the right square at the right time
this position was reached and Hikaru
once again gives up the draw with Bishop
F1 he simply gives away the pawn he
simply gives away the pawn and he gives
Notre backck a chance once again to
execute the correct plan with Bishop B3
Bishop G5 and F4 which Notre backck does
doesn't do as we'll get to in just a
second what was the drawing move well in
order to draw the game black had to keep
the bishop sorry black had to keep the
bishop on D3 at all costs where were we
yeah black had to keep the bishop on D3
at all costs and so the correct move was
simply to shuffle with black king king
G8 now what Hikaru missed in time
pressure uh is that after a move like
King to E6 Black's Bishop is now free to
roam about the cabin here we simply Play
Bishop E2 and this is a very easy draw
but likely Notre Beck would have played
the far trickier move King to D6 which
sets up an absolutely devilish threat it
seems like black and continued to
shuffle and yet in this position out of
nowhere there comes an incredible
winning shot pause the video see if you
can spot
it okay the correct move yes is Bishop
takes G7 what we have been missing in
this exercise is a bishop sacrifice
clearing the way for White's king and
the F Pawn promotes by force E3 by the
way we have F6 check and uh we can just
play F takes C3 and F7 winning the game
and so it's crucial for black after King
D6 to push E3 E3 we've already seen this
type of idea opening up the Bishop from
behind and of course this position is a
very easy draw black just rep Parks the
bishop on D3 and now black sets up a
very simple blockade on the E6 Square
white can even push E6 it doesn't change
anything as you can see both of these
pawns are on light Square so they can
always be defended by the bishop and the
King can never be checked uh it will
never budge because it is on a light
Square another good illustration of the
drawish Tendencies inherent in opposite
colored Bishop endings but Hikaru he
didn't realize that the E4 Pawn was
important and so he gave that pawn away
he gave that pawn away Notre Beck took
it but Notre Beck went the wrong way at
first he played correctly King E5 and
this is where he missed uh the winning
approach with Bishop B3 and Bishop G5 he
decided to go the other way decided to
go back to G5 and now he decided this
was the last chance he can still go back
to E5 now he decided to play H5 this
gives away the win for good hikaro plays
Bishop D3 Notre backck has to create a
pass Pawn with F6 it is now too late to
revert to the correct plan because every
time white goes King F4 Black's Bishop
will return to E2 and harass the H Pawn
and after F6 to Notre Beck's great horor
he realized in this moment that there is
absolutely nothing that white can do the
critical point the critical difference
is that in this very same position if
White's King was on E5 this would be
winning because white would be able to
push the pawn up to F5 as it stands
that's it black has full control over
the F5 Square forever and white will
never be able to cross the plane to
cross H6 with either the bishop with
either the king or the pawn Notre Beck
tried he shuffled around but there is
simply nothing that he can do hikaro
even provoked H6 and it's still a dead
draw obviously if Notre Beck goes this
way then hikaro can meet him on B5 there
is nothing that white can do Notre
backck shuffled the pieces a couple of
times and quickly acquiesced to a draw
it's worth just staring at this position
for a bit and convincing yourself that
yes it is in fact a draw look at how the
block Ed on the light squares Works look
at how despite the fact that black has
only a king and a bishop black holds
back White's entire Army two pawns
included and that is how Mr Nakamura was
able to save in improbable fashion this
insane opposite colored Bishop ending
okay now I have one other brilliant
example um which comes from the game
Wesley so uh sorry Notre Beck of duscur
versus Dennis lasc but um this example
on top of some others I will save for
part two it's already been 55 minutes I
know I've already given you a lot of
material to chew on I really don't want
to bog you down with too much stuff I
know that can be detrimental so if
you're still watching if you're still
taking notes thank you so much uh these
endgame videos are a little bit risky
because I know I go fast I know there's
a lot of variations and I know that for
newer players uh some of this might be
tough to follow and that that is why I
always say pause the video have a board
next to you and it's always okay to make
mistakes you can see that I made a ton
of mistakes in presenting this video and
I'm not ashamed to admit that end games
are the most complicated part of the
game and the way that we learn is by
getting our hands dirty right by by
moving pieces around and understanding
the patterns um so we went through uh
discounting the fuan nitzki example we
went through five examples a quick recap
we talked about this devilish drawing
mechanism and the way that black parries
it with his knight uh we talked about
the under promotion in Carlson fuja we
looked at the supplementary game uh that
I played against fuia we looked at the
crazy end game in car charson Carana and
we finished with one of the most
instructive opposite color Bishop
endings that I have ever seen where
hikaro had the draw with G6 lost the
game with F5 and then somehow was able
to recover and hold the draw okay with
that folks the Whirlwind tour comes to
an end there will be a part two I
definitely want to look at Abdus toov
versus lavic as well as a couple of
other complicated end games but for now
I'm pretty exhausted that was a lot of
end games so give yourself a nice pat on
the back and I will see you in another
video soon thank you so much for
watching please feel free to point out
Corrections in the comment section um I
hope you enjoyed the video and found it
instructive I'll see you guys soon
[Music]
bye